the sacrifice of the mother is
exemplified profoundly by Michelangelo's
great sculpture the PA de Mary is
contemplating her son crucified Andrews
so that's his body after he's been
crucified it's her fault it was through
her he entered the great dream of being
so what's the meaning of this sculpture
it's a great sculpture it's just an
absolutely unbelievable sculpture you
just can't believe that someone could
exist who could make something like and
of course it wasn't the only thing
Michelangelo made right it was like
that's it it was something he just
tossed off in a couple of months while
he was doing other unbelievable things
but you know it's it's an it's an object
of contemplation which is why it's in a
great Cathedral in a great city it's an
object of contemplation and the idea is
something like well what what's the role
of a mother if she's awake I had a
client come see me a while back not very
long ago woman in a boat who's about 30
and trying to make decisions about her
life she was pretty career oriented and
so I asked her about although maybe
having a bit of trouble with her career
I've seen this many many times
so this is an amalgam this is a story
that's an amalgam and I talked to her
about the other elements of her life is
like well you know there's only five
things you do in life so you've got your
career down you know what do you do
outside of your career that's meaningful
and engaging how are things going with
your family could be your family of
origin your siblings whatever do you
have an intimate relationship and like
what's your plan for your own family
apart from those five things there's
sort of something like get some exercise
now and then don't eat too badly and try
to stay away from the drugs you know
that's that that kind of and the crime
that kind of lays out life and if you
miss any of those five things or if you
do any of those other things wrong then
you're in trouble and you can get away
with missing a couple of them but not
all of them you know and she said
something along the lines of well I'm
not sure I should bring a child into
this world I thought oh god Christ you
got to come up with something better
than that such a bloody cliche which is
what I told her I said you know
you must have thought that up when you
were 16 it's like really that's here you
can't do any better this is a very very
smart woman it's like really and they
can't do any better than that like yes
obviously this is a vale of tears and
you know a well of suffering and all of
that you know if you ask 30 people who
are wondering about having children why
they're wondering 20 of them will say
that and so that tells you how original
it is it's not original at all it's not
a thought it's like this little it's
like a it's like a it's a mean something
that lives in your mind it's not a
thought and it's certainly not something
it's certainly not something that you
should just take it face value in and
say oh well I'm not having a family then
it's like no no you kind of look at that
and you criticize it a little bit it's
like well the pop it's the other one
that's the other one that's very common
there's too many people on the planet
already I really don't like that
statement it's like just who are you
going to ask to leave just how are you
going to get them to leave you know it's
a serious question and who says there's
too many people what the hell is wrong
with people anyways sort of or running
around ruining the planet yeah it's like
I think it was the Club of Rome who who
prophesied by the way that there would
be so many people on the planet by the
year 2000 that there would be widespread
starvation and they were completely and
utterly wrong about that and I think it
was the Club of Rome who either compared
us to a virus or a cancer on the face of
the planet
it's like oh really that's what you
think about people hmm aren't you
something isn't that something to think
about human beings viruses and cancer
what do you do with viruses and cancer
invite them in and make them at home
it's like no you try to eradicate them
you've got a bloody well watch your
metaphors folks because it isn't clear
that you come up with them or that they
run you so you better watch them
so anyways Mary you know and Mary's the
great mother right that she's the mother
that's what Mary is whether she existed
or not is not the point she exists at
least as a hyper reality she exists as
the mother well what's the sacrifice of
the mother well that's easy if you're a
mother and you if you're a mother who's
worth her salt you offer your son to be
destroyed by the world that's what you
do and that's what's going to happen
right he's going to be born he's going
to suffer he's going to have his trouble
in life he's going to have his illnesses
he's going to face his failures and
catastrophes and he's going to die
that's what's going to happen and if
you're awake you know that and then you
say well perhaps he will live in a way
that will justify that and then you try
to have that happen and that's what
makes you worthy of the statue like that
but still the sacrifice of the mother is
it right to bring a baby into this
terrible world well every woman asks
yourself that question some say no and
they have the reasons Mary answers yes
voluntarily Mary is the archetype of the
woman who answers yes to life
voluntarily that's what that image means
and not because she's blind she knows
what's going to happen and so she's the
archetypal representation of the woman
who says yes to life knowing full well
what what life is not naive not someone
who got pregnant in the backseat of the
1957 Chevy you know in what a one night
of half-drunk idiocy not that but
consciously consciously knowing what's
to come
and then also allows it to happen
because that's another thing that's a
testament to the courage of mothers
my mother was good at this my mother's a
very agreeable person too agreeable for
her own good but that's what happens if
you're agreeable because you're too
agreeable if you're only good that's the
definition of agreeable and so she's a
nice person and it still is luckily
she's still alive and we've had a very
good relationship and I have always been
able to make her laugh which
which is a good thing and but she was
tough cookie that woman you know if if
remember once she came across I was out
playing in this baseball diamond little
diamond and empty lot really in this
little town I grew up in and I was about
10 and she walked by I was there with
bunch of my friends and I was about to
have a fistfight with this little tough
kid that I hung around with and there
were half girls on the team and the
fistfight had some relationship to
status maneuvering you know in
relationship to that anyways we're going
to have a fight and my mom walked by she
took a look and I could see from her
demeanor that she knew exactly what was
about to happen and she looked for a
second and then she walked by and I
thought whoa good work mom no kidding
it's like last bloody thing I needed at
that moment was for her to come charging
up and say you boys aren't planning to
have a fight are you it's like well yeah
mom we're we were actually planning to
have a fight and now that you came and
intervened I actually lost before the
god damn saying even started so two
thumbs up for mum she was also the
person that said because I had some
trouble with my dad when I was you know
it adolescent he had some trouble with
me so you know it was 50/50 that's for
now it's probably 70/30 with me on the
seventy end of the being the trouble and
anyways I left home when I was about 17
and she said something really
interesting when I left home she said it
was too good at home you'd never leave I
thought hey mom that's pretty good you
know for for an agreeable person you've
got a real spine man so that was pretty
good so so you know mother that says
this the mother is the person who also
says get out there take your goddamn
lumps because you're tough enough so
that you can handle it she doesn't say
you just stay down there in your bedroom
brooding away because the world is
unfair and treating you badly and your
suffering is too much she says yeah
there's a lot of suffering out there but
you're a hell of a lot tougher than you
think you are so